Live from New York, it's Monday night. A pine cone? Is that a special thing in New York? Oh, I was going to say, we got lots of pine cones in Canada. Why are we talking about pine cones? You know, I know the comedian who bombed tonight tried to make a callback that failed, but I've got a callback in this episode
纽约现场直播，现在是周一晚上。松果？在纽约这算什么特别的东西吗？哦，我本来想说，我们在加拿大有很多松果。我们为什么要谈论松果？你知道，我知道今晚那个表现糟糕的喜剧演员试图用一个失败的“呼应梗”，但我这集里有一个“呼应梗”，
that I think is going to be very successful, which is the callback to the reduce by key example that we gave earlier, where you want to reduce each row in a matrix. How'd you feel about the squid fries? I expected potato fries with the squid-like essence. Instead they were pieces of squid that were fried. So I was very shocked. If I could get it french fries at this hour I would. Instead of big algorithm library which is what we have today that we should have gone with small composable algorithm library. which is what we have today, that we should have gone with small, composable algorithm library.
我觉得会非常成功，那就是我们之前提到的“按键归约”（reduce by key）示例，你想对矩阵中的每一行进行归约。你觉得鱿鱼薯条怎么样？我以为是带有鱿鱼风味的炸薯条。结果它们是炸鱿鱼块。所以我非常震惊。如果我现在能买到炸薯条，我肯定会买。而不是像我们今天这样的大型算法库，我们本应该选择小型、可组合的算法库。
We're okay with a if-then situation, we're if dog-then cat. There, I tried to loop it back into technical things, because you guys refuse to talk technical. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, listen, folks. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 232 recorded on April 14th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host, Bryce, we record live from New York, we chat about algorithms, overload sets, libraries, and more. All right, go. Are we recording now? Yeah, you're not exactly walking in a straight line. What?
我们对“如果-那么”的情况没问题，比如“如果狗，那么猫”。你看，我试着把它绕回到技术话题上，因为你们拒绝谈论技术。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，听着，各位。欢迎收听ADSP播客第232集，录制于2025年4月14日。我是康纳，今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们在纽约现场录制，我们聊聊算法、重载集、库等等。好了，开始吧。我们在录音了吗？是的，你走得不太直。什么？
This line looks entirely straight. Should we do a sobriety test right now? Yes, we definitely should. Boom, boom. Actually, I think I would pass to be honest. We're here, potentially episode 232 on the streets of New York. Do you actually know what street we're on? Here, you hold the mic.
这条线看起来完全是直的。我们要现在做个清醒测试吗？是的，我们绝对应该做。砰，砰。其实，老实说，我觉得我能通过。我们在这里，可能是第232集，在纽约的街头。你知道我们现在在哪条街上吗？给你，你拿着麦克风。
You'll be doing most of the talking. I think we're on like 23rd and something. We just left the New York Comedy Club after seeing, I'm going to say two out of the five comedians were really, really good. No, I'm sorry, Shima. I'm gonna say two out of the five comedians were really really good. No, I'm sorry, Shima. I'm sorry. The guy who bombed... He was awful. Yeah, but him bombing was in and of itself amusing.
大部分时间都由你来说。我想我们在23街还是什么地方。我们刚离开纽约喜剧俱乐部，看了五位喜剧演员，我要说其中两位真的非常、非常好。不，对不起，希玛。我要说五位里有两位真的非常、非常好。不，对不起，希玛。对不起。那个表现糟糕的家伙……他太烂了。是的，但他表现糟糕本身就很有趣。
Just stop talking about pedophilia, folks. If the crowd's not into it, change topics. Don't keep on coming back to pedophilia. What is it? And like, I've seen people bomb at that club before and like they always when like they get desperate, they always turn to lewdness. It's like anyways, why are we in New York, Connor? We're here for a actually I don't actually know the official name. It is a I think I'm going to do my best and then Bryce will correct me.
别再谈论恋童癖了，伙计们。如果观众不感兴趣，就换个话题。别一直回到恋童癖上。这是怎么回事？而且，我以前见过有人在那家俱乐部表现糟糕，他们总是当变得绝望时，就会转向下流。反正，我们为什么在纽约，康纳？我们在这里是为了一个……其实我不知道官方名称。我想我会尽力说，然后布莱斯会纠正我。
It is for a modern CUDA C++ training, a recently developed state of the art training for targeting Nvidia GPUs. Is, how close was the title of quote, modern CUDA C++ training, end quote? How, I think I got, that is what I would call it because the actual official name, which is like fundamentals of accelerated computing and modern CUDA C++ is way too long.
这是为了一个现代CUDA C++培训，一个最近开发的针对Nvidia GPU的最先进培训。那个“现代CUDA C++培训”这个标题有多接近？我想，这就是我会称呼它的方式，因为实际的官方名称，比如“加速计算基础和现代CUDA C++”太长了。
That's a mouthful. But anyways, Connor is here in New York because, well, you weren't planning on being here. When did you even, when did this even materialize? So yes, to our global listeners, I was asked, today is April 14th, I believe. Apologies to my meetup attendees that I had to move a meetup that we were supposed to have tonight. I was asked initially one week ago on Monday if I was available to help with the training.
那真是拗口。但不管怎样，康纳在纽约是因为，嗯，你本来没打算来这里。你是什么时候，这事是什么时候成行的？所以是的，对我们的全球听众说，我被邀请了，今天是4月14日，我想。向我的聚会参与者道歉，我不得不推迟了我们今晚本该举行的聚会。我最初是在一周前的周一被问到是否有空帮忙进行培训。
And I said, if you really need me, the answer is yes. What is this? USPS Is that what you pointed at? A pine cone. Is that a special thing in New York? I was gonna say is we got lots of pine cones in Canada. Why are we talking about pine cones? Anyways, I was asked a week ago. I said if you need me yes, but I don't once again. I have to say folks said, if you need me, yes, but I don't, once again, I have to say folks, I'm sorry to disappoint some of our listeners, but if you can tolerate an opinion you might potentially disagree
我说，如果你们真的需要我，答案是肯定的。这是什么？USPS？你指着的是那个吗？一个松果。在纽约这算什么特别的东西吗？我本来想说的是，我们在加拿大有很多松果。我们为什么要谈论松果？反正，我是一周前被问到的。我说如果你们需要我，是的，但我不想，再一次，我不得不说，伙计们，我很抱歉让一些听众失望，但如果你能容忍一种你可能不同意的观点，
with, we are temporarily trying to boycott the states. It's not going very well because I'm going to be having three different trips down here over the next two months. This is the first of the three, but yeah, things are a bit crazy. Anyway, so a week said yes if you need me but preferably no it turns out they did need me you notified me on Wednesday I got approval on Thursday and here we are on Monday and uh yeah we're here with my beautiful fiance do you want to say hi sweetie hello what a lovely voice and uh and so yeah we were here for training the training I think went phenomenally. Well, and I should explain the like, I got asked to do this training like 10 days ago, which is a little bit short notice.
我们正在暂时抵制美国。这进行得不太顺利，因为在接下来的两个月里，我还要来这里三次。这是三次中的第一次，但是的，事情有点疯狂。总之，一周前我说如果需要我，是的，但最好不要，结果他们确实需要我，你周三通知我，我周四获得批准，然后周一我们就到了这里，嗯，是的，我们和我的未婚妻在一起，你想打个招呼吗，亲爱的？你好。多么可爱的声音，所以是的，我们在这里进行培训，我认为培训进行得非常出色。嗯，我应该解释一下，我大约10天前被要求进行这次培训，时间有点紧。
And it's not, this is not like a training I've done before. This was like an eight hour training, but I, you know, like I give a lot of talks. If someone asks me to give a talk at work, like I'm like, sure but they like I was initially told like other would be like 20 people and I was like all right that's fine like 20 people like we like to have a 10 to 1 ratio of instructors to students so I'm like I'll find one person in the New York area and so then I ask like there's a lot of people on my team who like live in New York there's maybe like four or five people and I ask all of them and they're like every single part like one person's like I gotta take my dog somewhere,
而且这不是我以前做过的培训。这就像是一个八小时的培训，但我，你知道，我做了很多演讲。如果有人让我去工作时做个演讲，我会说，当然，但他们最初告诉我会有20个人，我说好的，没问题，20个人，我们喜欢讲师与学生的比例是1比10，所以我说我会找一个纽约地区的人，然后我问了，我的团队里有很多人住在纽约，大概有四五个人，我问了他们所有人，他们每个人，比如一个人说我得带我的狗去某处，
one person's getting work done on the house, renovations, like everybody had something. I was like uh-oh and then and then like we have some planning meetings. Somebody's like oh yeah there will be 80 to 100 people and I'm like wait there's a lot more people than I expect and somebody's like, oh yeah, there'll be 80 to 100 people. And I'm like, wait, that is a lot more people than I expect. And so now like my search expands beyond New York and I'm asking like everybody who I even remotely work within Boston. And then I'm like, oh, Toronto's nearby. So maybe I'll ask Connor. Long story short, we ended up flying two people from Toronto in and then two
一个人家里在装修，每个人都有事。我说，噢，不，然后我们开了一些计划会议。有人说，哦，是的，会有80到100人，我说等等，这比我预期的多得多。有人说，哦，是的，会有80到100人。我说，等等，这比我预期的多得多。所以现在我的搜索范围扩大到了纽约之外，我问了所有我甚至在波士顿有远程工作联系的人。然后我说，哦，多伦多很近。也许我会问康纳。长话短说，我们最终从多伦多飞了两个人过来，然后两个
people from Boston came and then one person came all the way out from California for like less than 24 hours to do this training. But it turned out great. We had a great time. We taught people lots of things about Kudos, E++. Great questions were asked. A fun time was had by all, and I have not lost my voice yet. Professor Bryce is, maybe that'll be a thing.
人从波士顿过来，还有一个人从加利福尼亚一路赶来，只为了不到24小时的培训。但结果很棒。我们玩得很开心。我们教了人们很多关于CUDA C++的知识。提出了很棒的问题。每个人都玩得很开心，而且我还没有失声。布莱斯教授，也许这会成为一件事。
Maybe that'll be a thing. We'll see. And I will say, they were phenomenal students, if you will, I mean, they're all professionals, so maybe calling them students isn't the right word, but yeah, great questions. And there was one really interesting question. So one of the examples in the talk was,
也许这会成为一件事。我们走着瞧。而且我要说，他们是非常出色的学生，如果你愿意这么说的话，我的意思是，他们都是专业人士，所以称他们为学生可能不太准确，但是的，问题很棒。有一个非常有趣的问题。所以演讲中的一个例子是，
this is a problem that, a recent talk I gave on CUDA C++, I started talking about, I gave an example of using some of the reduced by key algorithms. We've talked about them on the podcast before, but we were, like the canonical example of reduced by key is you want to like reduce the rows of a row major matrices. Like you want to do one reduction for each row. So reduced by key, what it does is it takes a sequence of keys as an input and then a sequence of values as an input. And for each run of consecutive keys, so for each sequence of consecutive keys that are
这是一个问题，我最近关于CUDA C++的演讲中开始谈论的，我举了一个使用一些“按键归约”算法的例子。我们之前在播客中谈论过它们，但我们当时，比如“按键归约”的典型例子是你想要归约行优先矩阵的行。就像你想对每一行做一个归约。所以“按键归约”，它所做的是它接受一个键序列作为输入，然后一个值序列作为输入。对于每一串连续的键，也就是对于每一串连续的键，
all the same, it'll reduce that set of values. And so if you've got a row major matrix and you want to reduce each row, each row is contiguous. So the key that you use is just the row that that particular element is in. But what if you want to do a reduce by key of the columns? Well, the columns are not contiguous, so the key sequence for the column of each cell would be like 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. And reduced by key, it only works on, it only combines consecutive keys that are the same.
它们都是相同的，它会归约那组值。所以如果你有一个行优先矩阵，你想归约每一行，每一行都是连续的。所以你使用的键就是那个特定元素所在的行。但如果你想对列进行“按键归约”呢？嗯，列不是连续的，所以每个单元格的列的键序列就像0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8。而“按键归约”，它只适用于，它只合并相同的连续键。
So if you have a bunch of keys that have the same, you know, column ID but they're not next to each other in the key sequence, it doesn't matter, they're going gonna be separate groups. And so someone was asking, well how would you do reduce by key on that? And just there's, you know, you could have a new algorithm like an unordered reduce by key or one that like does a sort or something. But we were sort of theory crafting there and you know, Connor, I was saying I think you can do it with reduced byte key you just need the right type of iterator and Connor you suggested how it can be done. I mean it's quite obvious and and also
所以如果你有一堆键，它们有相同的列ID，但它们在键序列中并不相邻，没关系，它们将是独立的组。所以有人问，那你怎么做那个的“按键归约”呢？你可以有一个新算法，比如“无序按键归约”，或者一个进行排序之类的算法。但我们当时在进行理论推演，你知道，康纳，我说我认为你可以用“按键归约”做到，你只需要正确类型的迭代器，康纳你建议了怎么做。我的意思是这很明显，而且
too it's obvious for me because in a research project I implemented an algorithm that was called chunk fold where chunk is the equivalent of the C++ 23 chunk that takes an integer which which is basically this, right? You're doing a chunking by an integer size and then folding afterwards is the equivalent of doing a row-wise summation on a 2D matrix. And the way that I do that is exactly what you did. So the column-wise one is pretty intuitive and we have a fancy iterator in thrust called the permutation iterator and so you could just build up that index permutation sequence that gives you the columns. Would it be efficient?
对于我来说也很明显，因为在一个研究项目中，我实现了一个名为“块折叠”（chunk fold）的算法，其中“块”等同于C++ 23的“块”，它接受一个整数，这基本上就是这个，对吧？你按整数大小进行分块，然后之后的折叠等同于在二维矩阵上进行行求和。而我做的方法正是你所做的。所以列向的那个非常直观，我们在Thrust中有一个花哨的迭代器叫“排列迭代器”（permutation iterator），所以你可以构建那个给出列的索引排列序列。它会高效吗？
Definitely not. But it would get the job done. And so the idea here I think is that you would have the key sequence where you'd have all the column IDs contiguous and then you would, the value sequence would be the thing that would be the permutation iterator. So in effect you're doing like a reduce that also does a transpose of the data. Like a reduce by key with a transpose built in there. And it's actually interesting because there are more efficient ways to do a
绝对不会。但它能完成工作。所以这里的想法是，我认为你会有一个键序列，其中所有的列ID都是连续的，然后你会，值序列将是那个排列迭代器。所以实际上你做的是一个也对数据进行转置的归约。就像一个内置了转置的“按键归约”。这其实很有趣，因为有比排列迭代器更高效的方法来进行
transpose than with the permutation iterator and so like maybe we need to have some sort of transpose iterator that under the hood the library could recognize that it's a transpose and use some efficient transpose mechanism because the problem with doing like the the the reduce like the column summation the problem is that you're doing a gather. So you're striding through memory with these big strides and that can be inefficient. And so there may be a slightly more efficient way to do this. I don't know whether there's like some way to write some transpose iterator that's going to be better or that would be recognized by the
转置，所以也许我们需要某种转置迭代器，库在底层可以识别出这是一个转置并使用某种高效的转置机制，因为像列求和那样的归约的问题在于你在进行“收集”（gather）。所以你用这些大步幅在内存中跨越，这可能效率低下。所以可能有一种稍微高效的方法来做到这一点。我不知道是否有一种方法可以编写某种更好的转置迭代器，或者会被底层算法识别出来。
underlying algorithms. But it was a really good question that someone asked and now I want to go and I want to add it as another example to one of my talks. Did you have any interesting encounters with people today? Did you learn anything new? Did I personally learn anything new? I don't think so. But I think my overall takeaway is that the folks at this corporate entity that- I don't believe you. There's no way you didn't learn one new thing.
但这是一个非常好的问题，有人问了，现在我想去把它作为另一个例子加到我的演讲中。你今天有什么有趣的邂逅吗？你学到什么新东西了吗？我个人学到什么新东西了吗？我不这么认为。但我认为我的总体收获是，这家企业实体的员工……我不相信你。你不可能没学到一件新东西。
At least in the training. I didn't learn one. Oh, yes. I mean, actually I did learn, I thought you meant from the questions and the interaction with the students. But from the trainings, yes. I mean, similar to one of the other trainee individuals, I did not know what the third
至少在培训中。我没学到一件。哦，是的。我的意思是，其实我确实学到了，我以为你是指从问题和与学生的互动中。但从培训中，是的。我的意思是，类似于其他学员之一，我不知道三尖括号内核启动的第三个
integer parameter of the triple chevron kernel launch is, and that was for dynamic shared memory. Admittedly, I spend very little of my time writing raw kernels most of the time. Well, you should not. That's a bad... You should not do that. You should not do that because it's very hard to do that correctly, and there's libraries, and you should just use libraries Which is which is 67% of the point of the training is target thrust target cub
整数参数是什么，那是为了动态共享内存。诚实地说，我大部分时间很少写原始内核。嗯，你不应该。那是个坏……你不应该那样做。你不应该那样做，因为那样做很难正确，而且有库，你应该只使用库，这占了培训重点的67%，即目标Thrust，目标CUB。
We have many very optimized by kuda ninja libraries that you can use so that you do not have to write your own kernels and So I don't want to throw our other TA under the bus, but someone asked. What is that third? triple chevron parameter? And in my head I was like, yeah, I didn't get asked that question, but I would have also had to ask and it was for dynamic shared memory. So yeah, I definitely did learn. That was when TA knew the answer.
我们有很多非常优化的CUDA忍者库，你可以使用它们，这样你就不必编写自己的内核了。所以我不想把我们的另一位助教推到风口浪尖，但有人问。那个第三个三尖括号参数是什么？在我的脑海里，我在想，是的，我没被问到那个问题，但我也会不得不问，那是为了动态共享内存。所以是的，我确实学到了。那是助教知道答案的时候。
He just thought that everybody in the room should know the answer. And so definitely I learned a few things. What was a few of the times I was actually working through the training because I had not seen the training before. I always forget that with NVCC, generic lambdas are not supported. So I naturally always reach for auto type
他只是认为房间里的每个人都应该知道答案。所以绝对我学到了一些东西。有几次我实际上是在完成培训，因为我之前没看过这个培训。我总是忘记NVCC不支持通用lambda。所以我自然总是伸手去拿自动类型
in the parameter list of a host and device annotated lambda with NVCC, and that'll fail to compile. It's a simple fix, but almost like every single time for the first couple of examples, I would write that and then be corrected. There was a few other things too. I can't remember them all off the top of my head, but yes, from the training itself,
在带有NVCC的主机和设备注解lambda的参数列表中，那将无法编译。这是一个简单的修复，但几乎就像每次一样，对于前几个例子，我会写下那个，然后被纠正。还有其他一些事情。我记不清所有的事情了，但是的，从培训本身来看，
like not in the first half, definitely all of that stuff is my expertise. But in the second half of the training, definitely there was some stuff I picked up. I feel like there were other things we were supposed to talk about. God, I have a list somewhere. But after eight hours of talking and then a comedy show, my brain is not sufficiently there to remember things. But what else were we supposed to talk about?
比如在前半部分，绝对所有那些东西都是我的专长。但在培训的后半部分，绝对有一些我学到的东西。我觉得还有其他我们应该谈论的事情。天哪，我某处有个清单。但在八小时的谈话和一场喜剧表演之后，我的大脑没有足够的状态来记住事情。但我们还应该谈论什么？
I mean, we went to dinner. I mean, Shima was there. We can get Shima's review on the comedy club. Uh, you said what? Two of the? I think two of the five were good. The there was, uh, the first and the last, the first, the first and the second. The first guy who, who he had, he had a joke. His last joke was about that or his last sequence of jokes.
我的意思是，我们去吃了晚饭。我的意思是，希玛也在那里。我们可以得到希玛对喜剧俱乐部的评价。呃，你说什么？五分之二？我想五分之二很好。那个……第一个和最后一个，第一个，第一个和第二个。第一个家伙，他有一个笑话。他的最后一个笑话是关于那个，或者他最后一连串的笑话。
There was this reference to these tortoises being intimate, and the guy was wearing two or three jackets, and he kind of looked like a tortoise, and I swear it was intentional. I swear that man intended to look like a tortoise. He was funny. And then there was this tall Jewish fellow who had a very, very long face who was talking about his crazy neighbor, and I just thought I thought he was the best I thought it was hilarious. What say you Shima? We're giving the mic over to my fiancee her I
提到了这些乌龟在亲热，那个家伙穿着两三件夹克，他看起来有点像乌龟，我发誓那是故意的。我发誓那个男人打算看起来像一只乌龟。他很有趣。然后有一个高个子犹太人，脸非常非常长，他在谈论他疯狂的邻居，我只是觉得，我觉得他最棒，我觉得这太搞笑了。你怎么说，希玛？我们把麦克风交给我的未婚妻，她……
don't know not first time but you've been on the podcast few times before here we go we're sitting down which will try not to upset the other patrons. Sharing that comedy club is crazy. Nobody cares about what I think of a comedy. There are many people that care. Sharing that comedy club is crazy. Nobody cares about what I think of a comedy. There are many people that care. Okay, let me see. So my review of the comedy show is that admittedly it's better than Toronto comedy. We're very familiar with the Toronto comedy scene.
我不知道不是第一次，但你之前在播客上出现过几次，我们开始吧，我们坐下来，尽量不去打扰其他顾客。分享那个喜剧俱乐部太疯狂了。没人关心我对喜剧的看法。有很多人关心。分享那个喜剧俱乐部太疯狂了。没人关心我对喜剧的看法。有很多人关心。好吧，让我看看。所以我的喜剧表演评价是，诚实地说，它比多伦多喜剧更好。我们非常熟悉多伦多喜剧圈。
And I have to admit that the New York comedy is better. So I'll give you that admission. Other than that, there were five comedians. Two women, three men. Four out of five, I thought, were very funny. And I think objectively, people would think it was funny. There's just one guy that bombed. Which is okay, that happens.
我不得不承认纽约喜剧更好。所以我承认这一点。除此之外，有五位喜剧演员。两名女性，三名男性。五分之四，我认为，非常有趣。而且我认为客观上，人们会认为它很有趣。只有一个家伙表现糟糕。这没关系，这会发生。
Yeah, nobody really related with his jokes. And that's okay. But the other four were very funny. So it was a good night. Was it the other four? I mean, I know the last one, she was pretty good too. Was the other one pretty good? That's actually, the other one was very funny, yeah. She was the one that was like, yeah, like, people say like, don't you pray?
是的，没人真正与他的笑话产生共鸣。这没关系。但其他四位非常有趣。所以这是一个美好的夜晚。是其他四位吗？我的意思是，我知道最后一位，她也相当不错。另一位相当不错吗？那其实，另一位非常有趣，是的。她是那种说，是的，比如，人们说，你不祈祷吗？
She's like, I meditate. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Just in the same direction five times. They were all pretty good. That woman's one good joke. One good joke. Wait, before I move over, because we're separated by this big white table here. And we've got to record for at least like 50 more minutes to get a full episode out of this.
她说，我冥想。哦，是的，是的，是的。只是在同一个方向五次。他们都相当不错。那个女人的一个好笑话。一个好笑话。等等，在我移过去之前，因为我们被这张大白桌子隔开了。而且我们必须再录制至少50分钟才能得到完整的一集。
What else would you like to say? We went to a Korean restaurant tonight with some other Nvidia folks. A lovely dinner. We talked shop. A lot dinner, we talked shop. A lot of talk about the future, the plans for the training, the company. The singularity. The singularity, yeah.
你还想说什么？我们今晚和一些其他Nvidia员工去了一家韩国餐厅。一顿可爱的晚餐。我们谈论了工作。很多晚餐，我们谈论了工作。很多关于未来、培训计划、公司的谈话。奇点。奇点，是的。
What was your review of the dinner? It was a great dinner. What else is there to say? Lovely food, lovely company. How'd you feel about the squid fries? I expected potato fries with a squid-like essence. Instead, they were pieces of squid that were fried. So I was very shocked.
你对晚餐的评价是什么？这是一顿很棒的晚餐。还有什么可说的？可爱的食物，可爱的陪伴。你觉得鱿鱼薯条怎么样？我以为是带有鱿鱼风味的炸薯条。结果它们是炸鱿鱼块。所以我非常震惊。
And if I could get french fries at this hour, I would. And this is totally off-topic for this podcast, but we had two different individuals talk to us about our potential future acquisitions of pets, specifically dogs, and a little bit cats. Have we, has our, as a, you know, partnership, has our view evolved of what we will be acquiring? We're okay with a if-then situation. We're if dog, then cat. There, I tried to loop it back into technical things because you guys refused
如果我现在能买到炸薯条，我肯定会买。这完全偏离了本播客的主题，但我们有两个不同的人和我们谈论了我们未来可能购买的宠物，特别是狗，还有一点猫。我们，作为，你知道，合伙人，我们对我们将要购买什么的看法进化了吗？我们对“如果-那么”的情况没问题。我们是“如果狗，那么猫”。你看，我试着把它绕回到技术话题上，因为你们拒绝
to talk technical. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Listen, listen folks. That's a very technical podcast. I did my part. I did my part. Yeah, also too. You know, Bryce is known for, you know, we are Mr. and Mr. Tangent, you know, we talk about how many episodes have we had Bryce? All All right, say goodbye, sweetie, I'm gonna go over there and we're gonna continue recording. Goodbye. That's such a lovely voice.
谈论技术。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。听着，听着，伙计们。这是一个非常技术的播客。我尽了我的本分。我尽了我的本分。是的，还有。你知道，布莱斯以，你知道，我们是“切线先生和先生”，你知道，我们谈论我们有多少集了，布莱斯？好了，好了，说再见，亲爱的，我要去那边，我们将继续录音。再见。多么可爱的声音。
We're Mariner, folks, we're Mariner. How many times, Bryce, have we started recording an episode and like two minutes in, we went in a completely different direction and the first two minutes was, this is what we're gonna talk about, and then the remaining 28 minutes is we talked about absolutely nothing to do with what we talked about in the first two minutes how many times I think that's
我们是水手，伙计们，我们是水手。布莱斯，我们有多少次开始录制一集，然后两分钟后，我们走向了一个完全不同的方向，前两分钟是，这是我们要谈论的内容，然后剩下的28分钟是我们谈论了与我们在前两分钟谈论的内容完全无关的事情，有多少次？我想那是
it's been a lot of times I think that's like that's my fault I think that's on me for the most part oh gosh I'm trying to think about what else you're supposed to talk about oh yeah we can spin this into the topics that we had before that we never got to on the previous recording you wanted to so anyways this is, this is the, um, this is going to be one episode folks. We're going to, we're going to call this, I don't know, New York, New York plus something else. The training was great. Hope to do this again in the future.
很多次了，我想那是我的错，我想大部分责任在我。哦，天哪，我在想我们还应该谈论什么，哦，是的，我们可以把它转到我们之前有的话题上，我们在之前的录音中没谈到，你想要……所以总之，这是，这是，嗯，这将是一集，伙计们。我们要，我们要称之为，我不知道，纽约，纽约加上其他东西。培训很棒。希望将来能再做一次。
And I think the, yeah, the folks at the training, they, they loved it. I think they got a lot out of it and they were great spinning back to a couple episodes ago, the last time we recorded, we ended up doing the Tesla, or not the Tesla and talking about AI a bunch and we didn't get to overload sets. Do you wanna talk about overload sets right now? Or do you wanna talk about the stuff that we were supposed to bring up from earlier today?
而且我认为，是的，培训的人们，他们，他们很喜欢。我想他们从中得到了很多，而且他们很棒，回到几集前，我们上次录音时，我们最终做了特斯拉，或者不是特斯拉，谈论了很多AI，我们没谈到重载集。你想现在谈谈重载集吗？还是你想谈谈我们今天早些时候应该提起的那些事情？
Because we can take this in two different directions. I mean, that was one of the topics that you want. What? I don't know, I think there was a few other things that you wanted to talk about from earlier today but I'm not sure which one... Let's talk about the overload sets. I feel like I'm slowly... Oh god I'm turning into such a C++ personality. I feel like I'm slowly over the course of many years assembling content for a book which I know like every every person once they reach a
因为我们可以把这个带向两个不同的方向。我的意思是，那是你想要的话题之一。什么？我不知道，我想你今天早些时候还有几件其他想谈的事情，但我不知道哪一个……让我们谈谈重载集。我觉得我正在慢慢……哦，天哪，我正在变成一个C++个性。我觉得我正在慢慢地在多年间为一本书汇编内容，我知道像每个在C++社区达到
certain age in the C++ community starts reading a book but I've been thinking more about like design and and oh excuse me excuse me did you guys forget a phone oh oh Connor just noticed that somebody left a phone Connor the hero the hero, the hero. So, alright, I will, I hate to do this to my co-workers. I hate to do this to my co-workers. And I'll preface this by saying I don't mean to shame anyone, okay? I don't mean to shame anyone. I'm not, This is not a tactic to push forward any changes. However, I'm going to explain a situation. So we have an interface. There's this method on a... Should we move to these couches over here? We can move to those couches. We'll tell the
一定年龄的人都开始写书，但我一直在更多地思考设计，而且，哦，抱歉，抱歉，你们是不是忘了手机？哦，哦，康纳刚注意到有人落下了手机，康纳，英雄，英雄，英雄。所以，好吧，我会，我不喜欢对我同事这样做。我不喜欢对我同事这样做。我会以这样的话作为开场白，我不是要羞辱任何人，好吗？我不是要羞辱任何人。我不是，这不是推动任何改变的策略。然而，我要解释一个情况。所以我们有一个接口。这个类上有一个方法……我们应该移到那边的沙发上吗？我们可以移到那些沙发上。我们会讲
story about the cookies. All right, I'll tell the story about the cookies now. So we were at this training all day. I was doing the lecture part, and then there were these instructors who were going out for the interactive part. So I was talking a lot. And I was told at lunch, well, first of all, at lunch, I picked a box lunch that did not have a cookie in it. And I was sad, so then I picked a different box lunch
关于饼干的故事。好吧，我现在讲饼干的故事。所以我们整天都在这个培训中。我在做讲座部分，然后有这些讲师去进行互动部分。所以我说了很多话。午餐时有人告诉我，嗯，首先，午餐时，我选了一个没有饼干的盒饭。我很伤心，所以我选了另一个盒饭
that had a cookie in it, but that cookie was not particularly good. And then I was promised later in the day that there would be a cookie bar. And you know what happened? Connor, was there a cookie bar? There was not. And the patrons that were attending the training did get live updates
里面有饼干，但那块饼干不是特别好吃。然后我后来在一天中被承诺会有饼干吧。你知道发生了什么吗？康纳，有饼干吧吗？没有。而且参加培训的顾客确实得到了实时更新，
when we came back from break and there was no cookie bar. But then one of my co-workers who had come in from Toronto, Ashwin, he asked where I would get cookies from. And I mentioned, well, there's, you know from and I mentioned well there's you know Levine, Levine's, there's Mamon and a couple other places and then he offered to order cookies for the whole team and I was a little hesitant but I was like you know what I could use a cookie so we got these Levine cookies and these Levine cookies they are they're not really cookies, they're like cakes. They're like big, thick things.
当我们从休息回来时，没有饼干吧。但后来我的一位从多伦多来的同事，阿什温，他问我从哪里买饼干。我提到了，嗯，有，你知道从……我提到了，嗯，有，你知道Levine，Levine's，有Mamon和其他几个地方，然后他主动提出为整个团队订购饼干，我有点犹豫，但我说，你知道吗，我确实需要一块饼干，所以我们买了这些Levine饼干，这些Levine饼干，它们不是真正的饼干，它们就像蛋糕。它们就像又大又厚的东西。
It's like a thousand calories. But I ate one of them nice and warm, and it was just perfect. Anyways, back to Overload Sense. So yeah, so this, again, apologies to my coworkers. I don't mean to make anyone feel bad. But there's this method on a class and it's called weight. And there's two different overloads of weight.
它就像一千卡路里。但我吃了一块热乎乎的，它简直完美。总之，回到重载集。所以是的，所以这个，再次向我的同事道歉。我不是要让任何人感到难过。但类上有一个方法，它叫“等待”（weight）。“等待”有两个不同的重载。
One overload takes no argument and the other overload takes a object. And the first overload of weight, when you call it, it blocks the caller. The second overload of weight does not block the caller. It tells the object, you object should wait upon this thing that I'm passing to you. So like the object that you're calling it on is this thing that we call a stream. And so the first overload of weight that takes no argument, it says, hey, I want to block until this stream of work is finished. And then the second overload of weight says, tell this stream of work
一个重载不带参数，另一个重载带一个对象。当你调用第一个“等待”重载时，它会阻塞调用者。第二个“等待”重载不会阻塞调用者。它告诉对象，你对象应该等待我传给你的这个东西。所以就像你调用它的对象是这个我们称之为“流”（stream）的东西。所以第一个不带参数的“等待”重载，它说，嘿，我想阻塞直到这个工作流完成。然后第二个“等待”重载说，告诉这个工作流
to wait on another stream of work. But it does not block the caller. And I think that this is not the correct design, because I could understand if you just had the second semantics. If you had the function, you called it wait, but it didn't block, it just told the thing to wait upon some other thing. But I cannot abide having two overloads, the same thing, where one of them will block the caller,
去等待另一个工作流。但它不会阻塞调用者。我认为这不是正确的设计，因为如果只有第二个语义，我还能理解。如果你有这个函数，你调用它“等待”，但它不阻塞，它只是告诉那个东西去等待其他东西。但我无法忍受有两个重载，同一个东西，其中一个会阻塞调用者，
but the other one will not block the caller. I think that this is confusing, and I think that this is not good interface design. And I feel that a good overload resolution set should have the same semantic behavior, and for anything that has a subtlety, like for example, whether a parameter is modified, whether or not the function blocks, things like that, anything that's got caveats that requires nuance to understand should be the same across all of
但另一个不会阻塞调用者。我认为这令人困惑，我认为这不是好的接口设计。而且我觉得一个好的重载解析集应该有相同的语义行为，对于任何有微妙之处的东西，例如，参数是否被修改，函数是否阻塞，诸如此类，任何有需要细微差别才能理解的注意事项的东西，都应该在那个重载集的所有成员中保持一致。
the members of that overload set. And if there is two different overloads in this overload set have some subtle nuanced differences, like one of them synchronizes and one of them does not, then those should be two separate functions. Or if one of them modifies a parameter and one of them does not modify that parameter, those should be two separate functions. And I feel like there is some fundamental design principle here that belongs in the Book of Bryce API design.
如果这个重载集里有两个不同的重载，有一些微妙的细微差别，比如其中一个同步而另一个不同步，那么那些应该是两个独立的函数。或者如果其中一个修改参数而另一个不修改该参数，那些应该是两个独立的函数。而且我觉得这里有一些属于“布莱斯API设计之书”的基本设计原则。
The Book of Bryce. I look forward to reading that. Honestly, that is what I would call it, I'm sure, because, you know, my ego is very large. Yeah, I mean, I like it. I like it. I mean, I don't think anyone would expect anything less. Honestly, I have nothing to add. I completely agree. And when I was trying to brainstorm in my head, what are the good overloaded functions or APIs
布莱斯之书。我期待阅读它。老实说，这就是我会称呼它的方式，我肯定，因为，你知道，我的自我非常大。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我的意思是，我不认为有人会期待更少。老实说，我没什么可补充的。我完全同意。当我试图在脑海中集思广益时，什么是好的重载函数或API
that I can think of? Like, the one that came to mind is from Clojure. It's a partition function that is kind of a sliding window or chunking function where it takes a sequence and chunks it into different sequences. I don't remember what the default behavior is. I think it's a chunking behavior, but it has overloads of it which lets you set the stepping and like the windowing size, you know, and you know, it's basically that the API that has the fewest parameters just has defaults basically for the others. So the behavior is achievable by the one that has an overload that has more parameters.
我能想到的？比如，我想到的一个是来自Clojure。它是一个分区函数，是一种滑动窗口或分块函数，它接受一个序列并将其分块成不同的序列。我不记得默认行为是什么。我想它是分块行为，但它有重载，让你设置步长和窗口大小，你知道，而且你知道，它基本上是参数最少的API，基本上为其他参数提供了默认值。所以行为可以通过拥有更多参数的重载来实现。
And so definitely the what you're talking about here, it's like you can't get to the first weight function from the second one, because it's just completely different semantics so yeah I mean like you're telling me this and yeah it just sounds it just sounds like so I like that rule that if it's if it's an if it's got if the overload is that there's like multiple like a new additional parameters if it's like some of them are defaulted that that you should be able to get to the most defaulted version from the more explicit versions. I think that that is another good rule to go into the book of design. Yeah, I like that rule a lot. Well, there's another rule that I
所以绝对你在这里谈论的，就像你不能从第二个“等待”函数到达第一个，因为它完全是不同的语义，所以是的，我的意思是，你告诉我这个，是的，它听起来，它听起来就像……所以我喜欢那个规则，如果它有，如果重载是像有多个，比如新的额外参数，如果其中一些是默认的，你应该能够从更明确的版本到达最默认的版本。我认为那是另一条进入设计之书的好规则。是的，我非常喜欢那条规则。嗯，还有另一条规则，我
remember when we were designing my first committee paper, the binary binary transform reduce, there was or maybe it was one of the scan algorithms but there was it was one of these algorithms that takes a bunch of different parameters like it takes like two operators and then like maybe it was one of like maybe it was like the binary binary transform reduce so it took two operators and then an initial value and there was some question about what the ordering of the whether like whether it should be like operator one init operator two or like init operator operator and i thought that init operator operator made more sense but stl not the not the library, but the person who maintains the Microsoft standard library.
记得我们在设计我的第一篇委员会论文时，二进制二进制变换归约（binary binary transform reduce），有，或者可能是扫描算法之一，但它是那些接受一堆不同参数的算法之一，比如它接受两个运算符，然后，也许是像二进制二进制变换归约，所以它接受两个运算符，然后一个初始值，关于顺序是什么，是否应该是“运算符1，初始值，运算符2”或者“初始值，运算符，运算符”，我以为“初始值，运算符，运算符”更有意义，但STL，不是库，而是维护微软标准库的人。
He made this argument that when you have these additional parameters for new overloads, that they should be additive, that the order should be the same. If you have a three argument version and a four argument version, that the position of the arguments should not move. Like if the third argument should not become the fourth argument in the next overload. That if it was the third argument in the version that had just three arguments, that it should remain the third argument and that the fourth argument should be added.
他提出了这个论点，当你为新重载有这些额外参数时，它们应该是累加的，顺序应该是相同的。如果你有三个参数版本和四个参数版本，参数的位置不应该移动。比如第三个参数不应该在下一个重载中变成第四个参数。如果它是只有三个参数的版本中的第三个参数，它应该保持为第三个参数，而第四个参数应该被添加。
And that that was why you should have this somewhat unintuitive ordering where it's like operator, init, operator, instead of having the init come before both of the operators. And I thought that that made sense, too. And I guess it helps with overload resolution to avoid ambiguities in some cases, too. But his argument was not about the disambiguating. His argument was just that this is the more natural way
而且这就是为什么你应该有这种有点反直觉的顺序，比如“运算符，初始值，运算符”，而不是让初始值出现在两个运算符之前。而且我觉得那也很有道理。而且我猜它在某些情况下也有助于重载解析以避免歧义。但他的论点不是关于消除歧义。他的论点只是这是更自然的方式
to have it be. And that was compelling to me. What's interesting about that is I agree with what you're saying but I know the exact thing you're talking about and that is that the thrust transform reduce and the C++17 stood transform reduce have a different parameter order. And I'm almost positive that thrust is the one that does binary operator, init binary operator, but the std transform reduce from C++17 does init operator operator. Which it is possible that younger Bryce was stubborn and at the time fought for and successfully advocated
让它成为那样。这对我很有说服力。关于这一点有趣的是，我同意你所说的，但我知道你谈论的确切事情，那就是Thrust变换归约和C++17标准变换归约有不同的参数顺序。而且我几乎肯定Thrust是那个做“二进制运算符，初始值，二进制运算符”的，但C++17的标准变换归约做的是“初始值，运算符，运算符”。这可能是年轻的布莱斯很固执，当时为
for the order that made more sense to him and only later, retroactively in my mind, I came along, I came around to agree with SDL. And it's also possible that we only realized the mistake too late and that we weren't able to fix it. Well, because I mean, a knit's always necessary. So I thought the one that was... I think this may have been in the order of maybe the parameters for the scan because inclusive scan and exclusive scan, because in exclusive scan, you always have to have
对他来说更有意义的顺序而奋斗并成功倡导，只有后来，在我的脑海中追溯地，我才转而同意STL。而且也有可能我们意识到错误太晚了，我们无法修复它。嗯，因为我的意思是，初始值总是必要的。所以我以为那个是……我想这可能是在扫描参数的顺序上，因为包含扫描和排除扫描，因为在排除扫描中，你总是必须有
the initial value, whereas in an inclusive scan, it's optional. So in an exclusive scan, the order is inputs, outputs, initial value, operator. And then for inclusive scan, it's operator, initial value. Because you can have the operator without an initial value with inclusive scan, but for exclusive scan you always have to have the initial value. So it might have been something around one of the scans or maybe around the transform scan algorithms, the compound transform scan algorithms, that may have been it, that the transform inclusive scan and transform exclusive scan.
初始值，而在包含扫描中，它是可选的。所以在排除扫描中，顺序是输入、输出、初始值、运算符。然后对于包含扫描，它是运算符、初始值。因为在包含扫描中你可以有不带初始值的运算符，但对于排除扫描你总是必须有初始值。所以它可能是在扫描之一周围，或者可能是变换扫描算法，复合变换扫描算法，可能是那个，变换包含扫描和变换排除扫描。
I remember it was something with two operators, and the transform inclusive scan and transform exclusive scan. I remember it was something with two operators and the transform inclusive scan and transform exclusive scan have two operators because they have the scan operator and they have the transform operator. Okay, yeah, that makes sense. If you're talking about the scans, I was thinking about the transform reduces. Somebody could go to like the meeting minutes from like 2017 C++ committee meetings and find when STL made these points. It would have been in like the library minutes from very early committee days. But I think that the key point is that this argument is not the specific history here,
我记得是关于两个运算符的事情，以及变换包含扫描和变换排除扫描。我记得是关于两个运算符的事情，变换包含扫描和变换排除扫描有两个运算符，因为它们有扫描运算符和变换运算符。好的，是的，这说得通。如果你在谈论扫描，我是在想变换归约。有人可以去像2017年C++委员会会议的会议记录，找到STL提出这些观点的时候。那应该是在非常早期的委员会日子的库会议记录中。但我认为关键点是，这个论点不是这里的具体历史，
but this argument that STL made that about that if you have an overload that takes two arguments and an overload that takes three arguments and an overload that takes three arguments and an overload that takes four arguments, and that it's additive, that the first two arguments are the same in all four of these overloads, that you should not move, or if it's the same argument,
但是STL提出的那个论点是，如果你有一个接受两个参数的重载，一个接受三个参数的重载，还有一个接受四个参数的重载，并且它们是累加的，即这四个重载的前两个参数都是相同的，那么你不应该移动，或者如果它是同一个参数，
you should not move around its position across different overloads. And I think that was compelling to me. Yeah, I mean, that completely syncs with my sense of like you should be able to replicate like for instance in in the same kind of partition function enclosure that leads to a couple of these sliding chunking functions. Haskell only provides you the most generic version where you provide a step value and a window value Which you can spell the stride chunk and slide versions by specifying one and a value of n for either or the parameters
你不应该在不同的重载中改变它的位置。我觉得这对我很有说服力。是的，我的意思是，这完全符合我的感觉，比如你应该能够复制，例如在同一个分区函数闭包中，这导致了几个滑动分块函数。Haskell只为你提供最通用的版本，你提供一个步长值和一个窗口值，你可以通过为其中任何一个参数指定1和n的值来拼写出步长分块和滑动版本。
But the point being is like at the generic level you have you can spell everything You know, it's like it's when you I posted that blog post once that talks about how stood mismatch is the most generic version of a bunch of, you know, is sorted and whatnot. What? Like sometimes you don't need two sequences. You just need one sequence. And so you can ignore the second iterator to, you know, you're kind of bending and what a what a bend call it. It's like you're you're bending the algorithms in a perverse way. That's not how they're intended to be used,
但重点是，在通用层面上，你可以拼写出所有东西。你知道，就像我曾经发过的那篇博客文章，谈论std::mismatch是如何成为一堆函数（如is_sorted等）的最通用版本。什么？有时候你不需要两个序列。你只需要一个序列。所以你可以忽略第二个迭代器，你知道，你有点在弯曲，弯曲叫什么来着？就像你在以一种反常的方式弯曲算法。这不是它们原本打算被使用的方式，
but you can spell a single iterator reduction with a two iterator algorithm by just ignoring one of them or discarding one of them. And it's this idea that at the top level, you wanna be able to spell everything. And so anyways, to getting back to the wait API, if you've got different semantics and it's doing different things that, yeah, just,
但你可以通过忽略或丢弃其中一个，用双迭代器算法来拼写单迭代器归约。这就是那种在顶层，你想要能够拼写出一切的想法。所以无论如何，回到wait API，如果你有不同的语义，并且它在做不同的事情，那么，是的，只是，
I have nothing to add to that in that other than that. I agree. If it's got different semantics, that sounds like it should be two different APIs, right? And what you were talking about about discarding there made me think of, we have this special iterator in Thrust called a discard iterator. And it's something that I don't think we ever really see.
除了我同意这一点之外，我没什么可补充的。如果它有不同的语义，那听起来它应该是两个不同的API，对吧？你刚才谈到的关于丢弃的内容让我想起，我们在Thrust中有一个特殊的迭代器叫discard iterator（丢弃迭代器）。我不认为我们真的见过它。
We don't have in the standard library. And it's because there's not really algorithms that need it. And the reason is, I don't think there's any algorithms really in the standard library that take two outputs, are there? There is only a sync. Actually, let's play a game. It came up in a past episode, probably the listeners might know.
我们在标准库中没有它。这是因为并没有真正需要它的算法。原因在于，我不认为标准库中真的有任何算法需要两个输出，是吗？只有一个同步。其实，我们来玩个游戏。它在过去的一集中出现过，可能听众们会知道。
There's only one algorithm that outputs to two different output iterators. Can you name it? Probably not. Is it one of those set ones or something? Or like the partition or something? It is, it is is it is partition copy so partition part takes a unary predicate and everything that passes it writes to the beginning and then everything that fails writes to the end so that you end up with a partitioned kind of predicate
只有一个算法输出到两个不同的输出迭代器。你能说出它的名字吗？可能不行。是那些集合相关的算法之一吗？还是像partition（分区）之类的？它是，它是，它是partition_copy，所以partition部分采用一元谓词，所有通过它的内容写入开头，然后所有失败的内容写入结尾，这样你最终会得到一个分区类型的谓词。
sorted sequence partition copy does the same thing but it just's a linear pass. Anything that passes writes to the first output. Anything that fails writes to the second output. Other than that, though, so yeah, potentially, if you only cared about the first, but if you only care about the first predicate passing elements, that's just a copy of. You don't need to use a partition copy with a discard iterator on the second output iterator.
排序序列partition_copy做同样的事情，但它只是一个线性遍历。任何通过的内容写入第一个输出。任何失败的内容写入第二个输出。不过除此之外，是的，可能如果你只关心第一个，但如果你只关心第一个谓词通过的元素，那只是一个copy。你不需要在第二个输出迭代器上使用带有丢弃迭代器的partition_copy。
We have an algorithm for that, which is why it probably doesn't exist. And, you know, I know the comedian who bombed tonight tried to make a callback that failed, but I've got a callback in this episode that I think is going to be very successful, which is the callback to the reduce by key example that we gave earlier, where you want to reduce each row in a matrix. And these by key algorithms in Thrust that take with a keys input and a values input, they take two outputs, a keys output and a values output.
我们有专门的算法，这就是为什么它可能不存在。而且，我知道今晚那个表现糟糕的喜剧演员试图做一个回调但失败了，但我在这集中有一个我认为会非常成功的回调，那就是我们之前给出的reduce_by_key示例，你想归约矩阵中的每一行。这些Thrust中的by_key算法接受键输入和值输入，它们接受两个输出，一个键输出和一个值输出。
And this is useful because in some cases, you want to keep the association of this was the key for this group, this group of values that I reduced, this value that's the aggregate of this group. I want to know what the key is. In the case of the row-wise reduction, if our key is what row am I on, then in this output vector, the index of each element in the output vector corresponds to what the row was.
这很有用，因为在某些情况下，你想保持这种关联：这是我归约的这组值的键，这是这组值的聚合值。我想知道键是什么。在行归约的情况下，如果我们的键是我在哪一行，那么在这个输出向量中，输出向量中每个元素的索引对应于它所在的行。
And so you don't need the key's output here. And you don't want to write the key output to somewhere in memory if you don't need it because that's gonna waste memory bandwidth and it's gonna waste storage and so thrust has this discard iterator and what a discard iterator does is it when it's dereferenced it returns this proxy object that when you assign to it, it just does nothing. So it just ignores the write. And because we have these by-key algorithms in Thrust,
所以你在这里不需要键输出。而且你不想在不需要它的情况下将键输出写入内存中的某个地方，因为那会浪费内存带宽，也会浪费存储空间，所以Thrust有这个丢弃迭代器，而丢弃迭代器所做的是，当它被解引用时，它返回这个代理对象，当你赋值给它时，它什么都不做。所以它只是忽略了写入。而且因为我们在Thrust中有这些by_key算法，
and we also have a couple other types of algorithms that take two outputs, and because of these, we have this discard iterator in Thrust. And I think it's most commonly used with the by-key algorithm. So there's a few other places where it's used. But until we introduce by-key algorithms to the standard library, it's not something that we would need.
我们还有其他几个接受两个输出的算法，正因为这些，我们在Thrust中有了这个丢弃迭代器。我认为它最常用于by_key算法。所以还有其他几个地方会用到它。但在我们将by_key算法引入标准库之前，它不是我们需要的东西。
But this is one of the fancy iterators that we have in thrust that we showed in the course today. But that's just not something that's in the standard library yet. Because there's a bunch of algorithms in thrust that aren't in the standard library that really ought to be like these by-key algorithms that let you do these batched operations and are really quite powerful.
但这是我们在Thrust中拥有的花哨迭代器之一，我们在今天的课程中展示了它。但这还不是标准库中已有的东西。因为Thrust中有一堆算法不在标准库中，但它们确实应该在，比如这些by_key算法，它们让你能够进行这些批处理操作，而且非常强大。
Well, I mean, we're gonna have to revisit this topic because, I mean, it's been too long that I've been working on the stuff that I've been working on that hasn't been published, but it is. Eminently. Eminently this year, especially after the most recent stuff that I've been working on.
嗯，我的意思是，我们将不得不重新讨论这个话题，因为，我的意思是，我一直在做这些尚未发布的东西已经太久了，但它确实是。非常。今年非常，特别是在我最近一直在做的事情之后。
It's gonna be out in the wild. People are gonna be able to use it, but two of the motivational examples that I talk about are Unique Count, which we spent much time in Venice many years ago. Was it many years ago? We don't know, but it feels like a long time ago. But Unique Count, which is really just a zip iterator with a not equal to pass to a
它将会在野外出现。人们将能够使用它，但我谈到的两个激励示例是Unique Count，我们在多年前在威尼斯花了很多时间讨论它。那是多年前吗？我们不知道，但感觉是很久以前的事了。但Unique Count，实际上只是一个zip迭代器加上一个不等于传递给一个
reduce, which ultimately I'm not sure if we actually ever revisited that topic. But anyways, unique count is a is a hand-rolled specialization of fancy iterator plus algorithm. Transform reduce, a hand rolled similarly spelled version of a fancy iterator, transform iterator, plus an algorithm reduce. And I realized there's a third one today in Thrust and it is tabulate, which is just a counting iterator, AKA IOTA for my array language fans out there, plus a transform. And it's one of my array language fans out there, plus a transform.
归约，最终我不确定我们是否真的重新讨论过那个话题。但无论如何，unique count是一个手工制作的“花哨迭代器+算法”的特例。Transform reduce，一个手工制作的类似拼写的“花哨迭代器、转换迭代器+算法reduce”版本。我今天在Thrust中意识到还有第三个，那就是tabulate，它只是一个计数迭代器，也就是我的数组语言粉丝们所说的IOTA，加上一个转换。
And it's one of my big motivating points is that we have these hand-rolled bespoke algorithms that are a combination of a fancy iterator and algorithm. But the algorithms that we provide you that do these are limited. It's tabulated. It's unique account. It's transform reduce.
这是我的一个主要激励点，即我们有这些手工制作的定制算法，它们是花哨迭代器和算法的组合。但我们提供给你的做这些事情的算法是有限的。它是tabulated。它是unique count。它是transform reduce。
And then outside of that, you have to go and compose them yourself. Whereas we could be providing you with an API that does this all behind the scenes and makes it a lot easier. Like it's still a fantastic resource. Don't go write your kernels by yourself. Reach for this stuff. But I think in the future we could be providing you a more ergonomically to spell this stuff
除此之外，你必须自己去组合它们。而我们本可以为你提供一个在幕后完成所有这些工作并使之变得容易得多的API。就像它仍然是一个很棒的资源。不要自己去写内核。去用这些东西。但我认为在未来，我们可以为你提供一种更符合人体工程学的方式来拼写这些东西，
that does it automatically behind the scenes. Stay tuned 2025. Hopefully going to get published. So one of the reasons why we do the, the composed operations, one of the arguments, like one of the arguments for things like transform reduce and transform inclusive scan and transforming exclusive scan, um, is that it's more efficient, uh, on some platforms, some backends, uh, for like the parallel version to have these fused algorithms instead of being able to... well, okay, the argument at the time is this is before we
在幕后自动完成。敬请期待2025年。希望能够发布。所以我们进行组合操作的原因之一，关于像transform_reduce、transform_inclusive_scan和transform_exclusive_scan这类事物的论点之一，是它在某些平台、某些后端上更有效率，对于并行版本来说，拥有这些融合算法比能够……好吧，好吧，当时的论点是在我们
had ranges. So the reason that we had like transform reduce was because it's more efficient than doing a transform followed by a reduce and we didn't have a transform iterator at the time. I think that was the argument. And there's also this claim that maybe thrust should have a tabulate because maybe there's some faster way under the hood that we could do transform plus counting in the radar. I think in practice, it's not. I think in practice, it just maps down to that.
有ranges之前。所以我们有像transform_reduce这样的东西的原因是因为它比先进行转换然后再进行归约更有效率，而且当时我们没有转换迭代器。我想那是当时的论点。而且还有一种说法是，也许Thrust应该有一个tabulate，因为也许在底层有某种更快的方法可以进行转换加计数迭代器。我认为在实践中，并不是。我认为在实践中，它只是映射到那个。
But certainly, there were some cases where there's something that could be expressed as composition of other algorithms where there's a more efficient way to do it. However, and there's an argument that we don't know what all of those cases are today, and that for common use cases, it makes sense to have a named algorithm so that maybe we come
但当然，确实有一些情况，有些东西可以表示为其他算法的组合，而有更有效的方法来做。然而，有一个论点是我们今天不知道所有这些情况，对于常见的用例，拥有一个命名算法是有意义的，这样也许我们能
up with some faster way of implementing it. And there's a bunch of cases in thrust where we know that there's a faster way of implementing the algorithm, but we implement it through composition today just because it's not been an important enough use case to implement the faster path. Even despite all of that, I think that there's an argument to be made that instead of big
想出一些更快的实现方法。Thrust中有一堆情况是我们知道有更快的实现算法的方法，但我们今天通过组合来实现它，仅仅是因为它还没有成为一个足够重要的用例来实现更快的路径。尽管如此，我认为有一个论点是，与其拥有我们今天所拥有的庞大算法库，我们本应该选择小型、可组合的算法库。我之所以有这种感觉的原因之一是，如果你认为算法库的表面积只是像几个关键的入口点，并在它们之上进行组合，第一，我认为这使得移植到有趣的新目标和后端变得更容易，
algorithm library, which is what we have today, that we should have gone with small, compos big algorithm library, which is what we have today, that we should have gone with small composable algorithm library. And one of the reasons I feel this way is that if you think about the surface area of the algorithm library as being just like a couple of key entry points that are in composition on top of them, one, I think it makes it easier to port to interesting new targets and back-ends,
特别是对于并行性。但我也认为，这会给人们关于如何组合的更强烈的直觉。如果不是拥有count，如果你只是拥有reduce，而不仅仅是拥有max_element，如果你只是拥有带有max的reduce。我认为如果人们必须编写带有max的reduce，而不是编写max_element，人们可能会更多地思考组合以及用可组合迭代器和ranges来定制算法。
especially for parallelism. But also, I think it would give people a stronger intuition about how to compose. Like, if instead of having count, if you just had, you And instead of having max element, you just had reduce with max. I think that if people had to write reduce with max, instead of writing max element, people might think more about composition in customizing algorithms with composable iterators and ranges.
这意味着他们更有可能使用带有某种组合事物的reduce，而不是编写自己的函数。所以也许我们在庞大的算法库上犯了一个错误，而一套更小、可组合的原语会教给人们一种不同的编程模型，这将使他们更多地思考如何组合事物，人们会花更少的时间编写原始的for循环和重新发明
And that might mean that they would be more likely to use reduce with some compositional thing instead of writing their own function. And so maybe we made a mistake in going with the big algorithm library and that a smaller set of composable primitives would have taught people a different programming model that would have made them think more about how to compose things and that people would spend less time writing raw for loops and reinventing
世界。我1000%同意这一点，我也思考了很多关于引入这种库、围绕它的教学法，你知道，有这些高级的通用scan、reduce、map。但该类别中还有其他算法。实际上在文档中，我不确定你是否注意到了我发给你的那个截图侧面的超链接，在每个类别中都有一个星号，一个索引映射。
the world. I 1000% agree with this and I have thought a lot about to like introducing this kind of library, the pedagogy around it and you know there are these high-level generic, scan, reduce, map. But there are other algorithms in that category. And literally in the docs, I'm not sure if you noticed on the hyperlinks on the side of that screenshot I sent you, there's a star next to, like in each category, one index maps.
map顶部有一个星号。然后其他一切都只是它的特例。有些算法被遗忘了，你知道，我的go translate网站，map_adjacent，这就是它在Haskell中的叫法。它最初在C++11中被称为adjacent_difference。然后它在C++23中被称为adjacent_transform。它被称为prior_in_queue。
There's a star at the top with map. And then everything else is just a specialization of that. And there's certain algorithms that like fall by the wayside that, you know, my who go translate website, map adjacent, which is what it's called in Haskell. It was initially called the JSON difference in C++ 11. Then it's called the JSON transform in C++ 23. It's called prior in queue.
它在Haskell中被称为zip_with。它是那种被遗忘的算法。所以人们甚至不按名字识别它，23中它被称为prior_in_queue，它在Haskell中被称为zip_with。它是那种被遗忘的算法，所以人们甚至不按名字识别它，但重点是教人们通用版本，给他们特例，但让他们知道，如果我们没有为你提供特例，它只是一个你可以传递给这些东西之一的自定义二元操作。我明白了，她必须转身离开。不要离开。
It's called zip with and Haskell. It's this algorithm that falls by the wayside. And so people don't even recognize it by name 23, it's called prior and Q, it's called zip with and Haskell. It's this algorithm that falls by the wayside and so people don't even recognize it by name but the point being is that teach people the generic version, give them specializations but let them know that like if we're not providing you the specialization it's just a custom binary operation that you can pass to one of these things. I see, she must turn and leave. Do not leave.
我要把这个放进这一集里。不要离开我。不要离开我。我以为她很高兴，伙计们，把头靠在我的胸口，享受摸头，但她无法忍受。关于二元操作和算法的又一个字。所以我们将在接下来的……我们说了两个，但我打算把它延长到三个。
I'm gonna put this in the episode. Do not leave me. Do not leave me. I thought she was happy, folks, with her head on my chest and getting head pets, but she could not suffer through. One more word uttered about binary operations and algorithms. So we're gonna wind this down in the next... We said two, but I'm gonna extend it to three.
我的意思是，我认为也许有一个中间地带，我们可以明确地定义那些作为组合的算法，说这些是组合，事实上在Thrust中，因为这通常是我们定义事物的方式，当我们教授Thrust或在文档中时，我们明确地说，你知道，事实上，这等同于那个，事实上它是那样实现的，我通常在谈论Thrust中的transform_reduce时，
I mean, I think there's maybe a middle ground where we could have just explicitly defined the algorithms that are compositions as saying like these are compositions and in fact in thrust because that's often how we define things like we when we're teaching thrusts or in the documentation we like explicitly say like you know like in fact like like this is equivalent to that and in fact it is implemented that way like I commonly when I'm talking about transform reduce and thrusts I Like, you know, like, in fact, like, like, this is equivalent to that. And in fact, it is implemented that way. Like I commonly, when I'm talking about transform, reduce and thrust, I often say,
我经常说，是的，在Thrust中，transform_reduce的实现速度只是用转换迭代器调用的reduce。我们没有为CUDA后端定制transform_reduce算法。我们只是依赖于那个只用转换迭代器调用reduce的通用算法。我认为告诉人们这一点，他们仍然可以调用简单的transform_reduce版本，但能够告诉他们这一点，我认为这让人们真正理解了组合方面。
yeah, in, in thrust, the speed of implementation of transform reduce is just reduced called with the transform iterator. We do not customize the transform reduce, you know, algorithm for the CUDA backend. We just rely on the generic one that just calls reduce with a transform iterator. And I think telling people that, they can still call the easy transform reduce version, but being able to tell them that, I think it makes people really get the compositional aspect.
它是最重要的算法，我们依赖组合来实现那种光速代码路径。不过有些疯狂的事情，希望这不会超过四分钟，当我们最初说两个，但我把它延长到三个，但它是，我明白了，我生命中的挚爱在蹭我的腿，告诉我她想去刷牙。
It's the most important algorithm, and we rely on the composition for that speed of light code path. Something that's crazy, though, and hopefully this doesn't go to four minutes when I, we initially said two, but then I extended it to three, but it's that, I see, the love of my life is nicking my leg, telling me that she wants to go brush her teeth.
我们要把这一切都留在播客里，伙计们。tabulate是计数迭代器的名字，这是一个命名很差的iota，所以就像C++中的名字。你认为，等等，你认为计数迭代器是一个命名很差的iota？我认为iota是一个命名很差的计数迭代器，这是一个命名很差的iota。所以就像C++中的名字。你认为计数迭代器是一个命名很差的iota？我认为iota是一个命名很差的计数迭代器。重点是有分歧。所以这就是疯狂的地方，伙计们。在C++11中，它被称为iota。
We're gonna leave it all on the pod, folks. Is that tabulate, is the name for counting iterator, which is a poorly named iout, so like, the name in C++. You think, wait, you think the counting iterator is a poorly named iota? I think iota is a poorly named counting iterator, which is a poorly named iota. So like the name in C++. You think the counting iterator is a poorly named iota? I think iota is a poorly named counting iterator. The point is there's disagreement. So here's what's crazy, folks. In C++11, it's called iota.
在Thrust中，它被称为sequence。作为Thrust中的一个迭代器，它被称为counting_iterator。所以我们有sequence、iota、counting_iterator。然后如果你把counting_iterator加到transform算法上，你就得到了tabulate。所以现在我们有iota，我们有sequence，我们有counting，加上transform，等于tabulate，而且最重要的是在rapids中，counting加transform迭代器是一个如此常见的模式，我们创建了一个新的迭代器叫counting_transform_iterator。
In thrust, it's called sequence. As an iterator in thrust, it's called counting iterator. So we've got sequence, iota, counting iterator. And then if you add the counting iterator to the transform algorithm you get tabulate. So now we've got iota, we've got sequence, we've got counting, plus transform, equals tabulate, and on top of that in rapids the counting plus transform iterator was such a common pattern we created a new iterator called the counting transform iterator.
所有这些都是为了说，是的，我同意硬编码其中一些，如果你有一条快乐路径，无论如何，但重点是你想要做所有不同的变体。所以只需构建可组合的版本。厨师之吻。最后的话，我们要签退了。
And all of this is to say is that like, yes, I agree that hard coding some of this, if you got a happy path, whatever, but the point being is you wanna do all the different variations. So just build the composable version. Chef's kiss. Final words, we're signing off.
我们在纽约，我们在Evelyn酒店。我不确定Bryce怎么回家。你最后的想法是什么，Bryce？告诉人们他们需要听到的。嗯，我只是在想，你知道，好吧，为什么我们有sequence、tabulate和counting_iterator的考古学是什么？我意识到，这是一个很棒的悬念，我意识到我们可以得到所有这些问题的答案，因为我们，我们的同事Jared，我意识到我们可以得到所有这些问题的答案，因为我们的同事Jared创建了我们一直在谈论的库。我们可以和Jared谈谈。
We're in New York, we're at the Evelyn Hotel. I'm not sure how Bryce is getting home. What are your final thoughts Bryce? Tell the people what they need to hear. Well, I was just wondering about like, you know, okay, what's the archaeology of why do we have sequence and tabulate and counting iterator? And I realized, and this is a great cliffhanger, I realized we could get answers to all these questions because we, our co-worker Jared I realized we could get answers to all these questions because our coworker Jared creates the library that we talk about all the time. We could talk to Jared.
我们需要和Jared谈谈，我们还要请来Georgie，他给出的，在我看来，可能是最好的。它和GTC 2025会议上的价格相当。我们得请Georgie来，因为这个新的Thrust动手入门，去Cub，写你自己的内核，以及你如何写出与Thrust和Cub提供的光速相匹配的自己的内核。我们要请他们来。我们要谈谈这个。节目说明中有链接。再次最后的话，签退。我能够忍住喷嚏直到你讲完。好吧，Bryce需要见
We need to talk to Jared and we're also going to bring on Georgie who gave, in my opinion, what might have been the best. It's up there with prices from the GTC 2025 conference. We got to get Georgie on because this new hands on start with Thrust, go to Cub, write your own kernel and how do you write your own kernel that matches the speed of life that's offered by Thrust and Cub. We're going to have them on. We're going to talk about it. Links in the show notes. Final thoughts once again, signing off. I was able to hold my sneeze in until you finished. All right, Bryce needs to see
你。我们将在纽约现场见到你。现在是周一晚上。她现在睡着了。她一直是个超级战士。再见。请务必在你的播客应用程序或adspthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。播客。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
you. We're going to see you live from New York. It's Monday night. And she was asleep now. She has been a super trooper. Bye. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你们。我们将从纽约为您进行现场直播。现在是周一晚上。她现在睡着了。她一直表现得非常坚强。再见。请务必在您的播客应用程序中或访问adspthepodcast.com查看这些节目说明，以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。